we'll connect to new rock stars I'm Erik
Bosse and the price of Skywalker takes a
page from the Avengers in-game playbook
in the way the film prioritizes above
all else
nostalgia callbacks the dualistic
harmony that George Lucas thinks is
poetry it's as if this film was made for
nerds like us to pull apart and save her
like a nephews gingerbread house oh no
must have been world hunger ooh let's
break down star wars episode night scene
by scene for all the Easter eggs and
deeper symbolism that you might have
overlooked in to complete my collection
of breakdowns every Star Wars
installment spoiler warning if you have
not seen the film yet here we go the
opening crawl declares the dead speak
exclamation point a callback to were
into the Sith opening with war
exclamation points and in a sense the
first of many meta commentaries in the
rise of Skywalker that the lessons of
the last Jedi are worth re-examining
that film urged us to let the past die
in a Miss film the past roars back with
a vengeance the opening text describes
Palpatine as the Phantom Emperor because
as we saw in our episode one breakdown
The Phantom Menace of this entire series
has been Palpatine actually the
puppeting recordings that are mentioned
in this prologue actually be heard in
the game for tonight at last and work of
generations is complete the great error
is corrected the day of victory is at
hand
day of revenge the day of the sea' cross
of alta we open on kylo Ren wrecking
soldiers in a forest of fire as he
searches for a Sith wayfinder a
pyramid-shaped compass used to find the
Sith homeworld their shape actually
matches the Sith holocron
kylo arrives at the Sith temple on EXA
goal which is lined with enormous sits
statues similar to the ancient Jedi
statues and the ruins of jena on robe
one unlike those these statues are still
standing reflecting how the seth are
still very much alive kylo hears the
voice of Palpatine another key retcon
here andy serkis returns as Snoke James
Earl Jones returns as Darth Vader which
dissolve into ian mcdiarmid as the
emperor who reveals that it was he who
posed as the mentor influences in kylo
said all this time all this time
kylo passes pods containing what look
like Snoke clones suggesting that Snoke
might have been genetically engineered
capitainesj voice says is a pathway
queen these same exact words he used in
prevented the Zeppelin telling Anakin
the story of his old master Darth
Plagueis the wise and these secrets of
immortality flashes of lightning
illuminate Palpatine resurrected his
appearances ooh undercooked he's hanging
from a life-support rigging bony finger
stubs no people's eyes milky white he's
monstrous something out of a horror film
like be able dead
the Snoke clones plus the plague is seen
callback suggests that Palpatine has
returned using a combination of genetic
engineering and Sith immortality but I'm
actually doing another video explaining
all things Palpatine so Palpatine
reveals what was once the first order
will now be the final order the origin
of the first order was actually revealed
in the book aftermath empires end in
which the imperial star destroyer the
Eclipse retreated from the battle of
jakku into the Unknown Regions with
Grand Admiral Sloan and general Hux
planning to Train child soldiers to
rebuild the Empire saying that that will
be their first order but now that name
is revealed to set up this final order
which echoes Hitler's Final Solution in
World War two in which it was decided
that
European Jews and other groups that the
Nazis considered undesirable would be
exterminated Palpatine's planned of
everybody gets a dead star is the same
kind of unspeakably inhumane
extermination then on the Millennium
Falcon Pope in and Chewie play hollow
chess and post as Chuy's like 250 years
old
technically Chuy's about 235 years old
he was born in 200 BBY and rises
Skywalker is set in 35 ABY they're
joined by Claude a new character played
by Nick Kelton who also played biston in
rogue one they get intel that was passed
from a first-order spy and they outrun
Tie Fighters with poet piloting and then
of the gunner shape paralleling their
escape in the force awakens and they
Lightspeed skipped from planet to planet
a further step of the hyperspace jump
within and that was fear introduced in
the force awakens and their nearly
swallowed by a giant slug similar to the
XO goth and Empire rate reigns on the
jungle planet of engine cloths with
rocks orbiting her like the rocks she
levitated in the last Jedi and she
chants be with me but she's unable to
connect with the ghost of the Jedi past
because it's not the end of the movie
yet she trains with a combat remote
droid and a blast shield helmet just as
Luke did in a new hope but kylos
meditation with Vader's mask disrupts
her concentration sends her into a
flashback to her force dream and now
frustrated she attacks a droid with her
saber and failing that she crushes it
with her weapon of choice for old Bo
staff a reflection of the classic nature
versus Technology theme that we saw in
Return of the Jedi the resistance
soldiers include a Mon Calamari named F
tube and Po actually calls him junior in
the seen the rise of Skywalker prelude
connick revealed that F tab is actually
Admiral Ackbar's son yep Akbar as I'm
sure he told his wife wearing condoms
was a trap and he's actually voiced by
the movies co screenwriter Chris Terrio
dominic monaghan joins the cast as
Beaumont and also returning our Greg
Grunberg as that Wexley me in number and
Rose Tico who still wears that medallion
necklace that she shared with her sister
the late Carrie Fisher returns as Leia
now called master by Rey as she
undergoes Jedi training so JJ Abrams
rotoscoped archive footage of the Chiron
2 a-standin repurposing to lead a
dialogue from previous film never
underestimate a Troy
raise Jedi training also comes from
reading the ancient texts that she
swiped from Luke's home in the last Jedi
kylo Ren reforge 'as the broken shards
of his mask and now the fused cracks
resemble the Japanese pottery art of
Kate Sookie in which fractured pottery
is reassembled with
gold or other adhesives reflecting the
philosophy that nothing has ever truly
broken and can take on a new beauty in
its repair reflecting the redemption of
bends solos soul in this film in a
meeting with the first order high
command one dissenting general mocks the
cult mentality thus if calling them
conjurer's and soothsayers obviously
echoing the great Admiral body of the
first film your sad devotion to that
ancient religion has not helped you
conjure up the stolen data tapes and
kylo handles criticism even worse than
his grandpa did joining the cast is
Richard II grant as general in Ric pride
grant previously played the villain in
Logan ante modeled his performance ear
on Peter Cushing as grand moff tarkin
the heroes head to the desert planet of
Poisson ax shot and real-life Jordan
they find the akiaki tribe in their
celebration of life which Threepio
explains every 42 years and that number
is a nod to the release of the original
Star Wars which was 42 years ago in 1977
or if you're one of those nerds 42 is
also I guess the number from
Hitchhiker's Guide books
Oh what do you killings definitely
Douglas Adams in this festival race he's
a puppet show with a character throwing
something onto a bonfire foreshadowing
Rey later in the film on notch to a
young Aki Aki gives Rey a yellow beaded
necklace and asks her what her name is
and is a real stickler Aki Aki and asks
her last name too
this brings up the deeper theme of the
rise of Skywalker identity Rey is told
in this film never be afraid of who you
are and over and over again she is asked
who she is raised conflict in this film
is to fight the identity she was born
with with the identity she chooses for
herself
kylo connects with Rey and another
forced time chat like the ones we saw in
the last Jedi he snatches the yellow
necklace teleporting it through the
force to determine their location this
is a key device and the rise of
Skywalker and this device is color coded
the three films of the modern trilogy
follow a pattern of yellow red than blue
the force awakens has mostly yellow
palate the last Jedi is known for a
distinctive red imagery and the rise of
Skywalker is a very blue film JJ Abrams
follows that pattern here kylo force
times the yellow necklace and act to Rey
spills the red grain from kid Jimmy into
kylos chamber and so in act 3 we're
gonna be looking for a blue object
that's gonna get teleported of course
luke's blue lightsaber so they run into
Lando Calrissian
with Billy Dee Williams returning for
the role he's disguised when they first
find him as he was not too
in return the Jedi he explains that he
and Luke once together try to follow the
footsteps of a Jedi killer named og a
bass tune in the forbidden desert Lando
says that there are only two Sith
wayfinders remaining reflecting in the
classic Sith rule of two if you think
about it later kylo shatters one of
those wayfinders foreshadowing his
coming break from the sith ordered TIE
fighters arrive Lando drops the
trademark line I have a bad feeling
about this
and he tells ray give Leia my love a
call back to his hots for her and the
Empire Strikes Back
well actually we learn and so low that
Lando has hots for everything humans
Androids then asks poe how he knows how
to hotwire the skiff setting up another
identity themed subplot for Poe his past
revealed as a spice runner spice being
the inner universe term for drugs and so
a drug runner later he snaps at Finn and
Rey you used to be a stormtrooper used
to be a scavenger we can do this all day
a humorous statement of the theme that
one's past does not have to define one's
future they flee stormtroopers on the
skin
they fly now now we have seen storm
troopers have thruster packs in the
games first time in the films bb-8
throws a mop with an exploding canister
and Rey repeats Leia's never
underestimate a droid also setting up
how pivotal Threepio will be to this
story and they get swallowed by
quicksand echoing the Death Star trash
compactor scene but like Super Mario
Bros 3 the quicksand drops into a ke
pose speaks for kids everywhere by
lighting this flashlight like a
lightsaber yeah we've all been there Poe
and he cuts off Threepio by saying he
does not want to know what made the cave
just kind of another way of saying never
tell me the odds and they find OG
skeleton as well as his Sith dagger
which like the first time Rey touched
Luke's lightsaber triggers a nightmare
sequence but this time it shows her on a
SIF throne
SiC metal looking drone based on the
designs by Ralph McQuarrie for the
original trilogy now Threepio is unable
to read aloud the translation of the
sith runic language on the dagger he
cites a law passed by the Senate
forbidding droids from speaking that
language it's worth pointing out that
the Senate was controlled by Palpatine I
am Shannon though there's a chance that
he pushed through that law to keep its
goal hidden there's a Star Wars rebels
episode twilight of the apprentice where
ahsoka tano is actually required to
translate the old tongue which is
probably this language they encounter a
giant sand snake beast which retains by
force healing its wound this ability was
actually introduced into the Star Wars
Canon by baby Yoda in this week's
episode of the Mandalorian and I will
say it again
really what did come in handy with qui
gonn outside they run into the knights
of ren and kylo who faces down ray in
his new tie whisperer there are meta
doors showdown begins as a Western duel
with Rey framed in the classic
gunslinger pose but then ray turns and
runs along the same vector as kylo so
the shootout has become something closer
to a relay race Rey gracefully leaps and
slashes off the ship's wing but the
blocking can also be interpreted as the
passing of a baton in a relay race or
shadowing how Rey will pass off this
baton lightsaber to Ben in the final act
biron Chewie was taken on the first
order transport Rey forced pulls it back
and ends up in a tug of war with kylo
which ends with her accidentally using
Sith lightning to destroy the transport
little detail right before she uses that
lightning Rey gritted her teeth briefly
making the expression of the Emperor so
as they mourn what they think was
Chewbacca's death ray realizes that a
cheese ship is the same one from her
memory of being abandoned on jakku is a
girl
on the ship is the Droid do who speaks
garbled basic and is voiced by JJ Abrams
himself they had to catch Amin where
they meet up with posed former spice
runner contact sorry bliss played by
Carrie Russell they snoop a
stormtroopers in a bar that features
composer John Williams cameo Ian as the
bartender
his name is oma tres an anagram for
maestro they head into the Droid Shop of
Babu Frick voiced by Shirley Henderson
make a Moaning Myrtle from the Harry
Potter films into the background of the
shop is a battle droid from the prequel
films in the legs of a super battle
droid in order to hack 3 P O's inter
computer they have to wipe his memory
making this the second time
Threepio gets his memory wiped following
Bail Organa wiping him at the end of
Revenge of the Sith
they tell Threepio you know the odds
better than any one another never tell
me the odds call back Babu reboots him
and three POS eyes glow red as he
translates the Sith dagger directing
them to a moon of the Endor system and
as they leave Threepio shrieks this is
madness a callback to the first spoken
line of these Star Wars films this is
madness but before continue thank you do
hellofresh for sponsoring this episode
hello fresh is America's number one meal
kits with them you get easy seasonal
recipes and pre measured ingredients
delivered right to your door all you
gotta do is cook and enjoy I'm not much
of a chef to be honest most of my meals
come from drive-through windows but
hellofresh makes cooking so simple with
their step-by-step recipes and
pre-measured ingredients it's also
affordable hello fresh is now from five
dollars sixty six cents per serving
that's cheaper than fast food
I recently cooked the hello fresh meal
Tuscan sausage and pepper spaghetti the
ingredients were fresh the directions
straightforward and easy to follow even
as someone who suddenly gets like baby
hands need cooks a meal actually tasted
really great I never realized how much
you could spice up a simple familiar
dish with interesting seasoning and
fresh ingredients and just like trying
going off of a recipe that some other
expert made for you their meals are
really delicious with more five-star
rated recipes than any other meal kit
service hellofresh
offers flexible plans that fit your
lifestyle easily change your delivery
days or food preferences and skip a week
whenever you like it started with nine
free meals that's 90 dollars off your
first month of hellofresh including
shipping just go to hello fresh comm and
enter new rockstars 9 again that's hello
fresh calm and in Turco to new york's
there's 949 free meals so they use
Zuri's first order captain's medallion
to sneak onto the commandership and
there's a moment
when kylos silences Hux by sticking his
finger in his face the same exact
gesture his father Han Solo made delaio
when she was at a loss for words on hot
an empire they get past a few
stormtroopers with a Jedi mind-trick by
Rey now I'm not sure but these two might
be cameos by Ed Sheeran and Harry Styles
who do play two of the stormtroopers
somewhere in the film Rey goes to kylos
chamber to retrieve the dagger in there
he gets in a second force time with kylo
and their duel shatters kylos pedestal
holding Vader's mask a pedestal that
appears to be made of obsidian suggested
that he may have retrieved it from
Vader's old castle on loose debar
general Hux freeze Poe thin and chewy
revealing himself as a first-order spy
who simply just wanted kylo Ren to fail
so that he could probably ascend and
kylo confronts Rey for real this time in
a hangar bay revealing the shocking
truth of Rey's parentage that Rey is a
flashback sequence shows Rey's parents
played by Billy howl and Jodi comer from
killing Eve we're never told really
about the circumstances of the birth of
Palpatine son like whether there was a
mother or if he was genetically
engineered or conceived the emetic
Lauria manipulation like the
non-canonical backstory of Anakin
Skywalker but Palpatine's son turn on
him and hit his daughter rey on jakku
before oh she found both the parents and
killed them kylo tells Rey that they are
a diet in the force two sides that are
meant to join and balance each other and
he offers Rey the opportunity to
overthrow Palpatine and take the throne
together echoing the offer that Anakin
may be a bad man in Revenge of the Sith
and together you and I could rule the
galaxy make things the way we want them
to be but Rey refuses and leaves with
the others on the Falcon telling finn
that she was to find Palpatine and kill
him herself so they head to the Endor
system not the same forest moon of Endor
where the Ewoks live but another nearby
moon where the wreckage of the second
Death Star landed after its explosion
the production design of this wreckage
is fantastic and I love how the Death
Star ruins are so massive that they
clearly affect the ecosystem of this
coastline bottlenecking all the waves to
create a violent storm surge like the
people of the wars past the corpses of
the machines continue to infect this
universe with death ray uses an
extension from the daggers hilt to
eyeball the location of the wayfinder
among the ruins similar I guess to The
Goonies finding one-eyed Willie's
treasure yeah it's kind of goofy but hey
I kind of enjoyed the pirate adventure
vibe of this film here they meet Janna
played by Naomi a key like Finn she's a
first-order defector with no memory of
her childhood since the first
kidnaps its soldiers as children she
mocks pose crash landings and he says
I've seen worse he's calling back his
crash landing of the TIE fighter on
jakku in the force awakens and yes that
was definitely worse Rey takes the
skimmer into the submerged ruins of the
Death Star
inspired by scrapped concept art for
earlier films that I'm so glad they
found a place for cuz this setting is
sick there are rusty and high fighters
stormtrooper helmets and armor discarded
suggest in some dark fate for these
soldiers were either they abandon their
armor and tried to swim for it or maybe
they died and their corpses brought it
out of their armor raised scales the
innards of this battle stations similar
to how we first saw her in the crash
Star Destroyer on jakku the column she
climbs is a reactor for the tracking
beam just like the one on the first
Death Star that obi-wan shut down she
enters the throne room and the music in
this moment is the same creepy high
notes at John Williams use during
Vader's unmasking and death and
returning the Jedi foreshadowing how at
the end of the sequence of Vader's
grandson
will experience a similar transformation
now despite all the dilapidation the
observation window is still intact in my
analysis of episode 6 I'd pointed out
how its design was based on a spider's
web in the same way that spider webs can
withstand storms and damage Palpatine's
web remains poised to trap his prey ray
finds the wayfinder in this Cimber
encountering an evil reflection of
herself with a maul style dual wield
lightsaber an image that ray can almost
relate with since she naturally prefers
her bo staff to a sword like in the SIF
cave in the last Jedi the dark side
knows that taunting ray with her own
reflection is the best way to exploit
her identity crisis as she battles her
doppelganger the red blades bold closed
around her blue blade biting them like a
pincer an evil Ray's face briefly
transforms into a Sidious like monster
similar to the Bilbo jump-scare and
Fellowship of the Ring and this leads to
the best duel of the trilogy Rey and
kylo on the wall of the Death Star
trench
waves crashing around them an elemental
inverse of the lava
crashing around Anakin and obi-wan in
Revenge of the Sith the visual details
here are so well refined you can see the
steam sizzling off their blades as water
pours over them and behind them the
turbo laser is streaked with rust like
an old battleship in every possible way
these two are fighting the wars of
generations past wars that they realize
at the end of this duel
they no longer need to wage blow after
blow Daisy Ridley and Adam driver heaved
with exhaustion each strike is
punctuated by John Williams Orchestra as
if being
really urged on by the ghosts of the
past and the dual ends not because
either ray or kylo has defeated the
other but because one of those old
ghosts interferes Leia holding the rebel
Madhavi and she gave Han in a new hope
Leia surrenders her strength to connect
with her son and Rey exploits this
hesitation to stab kylo with his own
blade feeling immediate guilt and
noticed how the moment this fight ends
the rain stops the waves settle does if
the Wars of the past give way to common
ground at the present and Rey force
heals kylos wound together
Rey and Leia help kylo feel love and
empathy for the first time in his
adulthood and revert him to Ben solo
helping Ben process this is a projected
memory of Han and I love the detail that
while Ben is soaking wet
on it's completely dry or maybe Harrison
Ford - scrawled at the PA with the hose
don't point that [ __ ] at me the
father-son reunion is a beat for beat
replay of Hans death in the force
awakens then lifts his hilt sane in
order to do without a roof over the
strength to do it and Han touches his
face lovingly and been finally whimpers
dad a huge concession for a loner who
previously had no father and hearing
this subtextual I love you
han responds the perfect way I know
no one's been tosses his lightsaber
Palpatine rallies with general pride and
he refers to Leia as the princess of
Alderaan it's interesting how Palpatine
describes her as she was in a new hope
not as kylos mother / Vader's daughter
or general Organa it may reflect
Palpatine's frustration with his own
family tree how direct offspring can
sometimes be rebellious disowned
disappointments that make it harder for
the grandparents to course-correct to
the family legacy
so Palpatine disowns Leia from Vader's
legacy as he disowns his son from his
own legacy which he plans to skip the
generation and continue with Rey so they
blow up kid Jimmy and Rey returns to a
ch2 and porks watched as she prepares to
follow and Luke's cynical footsteps but
Luke's Force Coast stops her from
chucking his lightsaber saying a Jedi's
weapon deserves more respect
another meta and Tiff's assist from the
last Jedi Luke counsels her the same way
that Obi Wan's ghost counseled him in
Return of the Jedi
revealing a lightsaber previously owned
by Leia and a flashback of the two of
them training as Jedi in a forest
location maybe it's and or maybe it's
the oven for they use archived footage
of Mark Hamill and Carrie Fisher's
younger appearances here and Luke races
his submerged x-wing from the water as
Yoda did on Dagobah an empire with John
Williams score blasting the same Yoda
theme and with Luke's x-wing and kylos
wayfinder Rey guides a resistance to ex
goal using Luke's famous red 5 signal
and as a resistance prepares to strike
they mentioned a holo maneuver referring
to hold those kamikaze hyperspace strike
on the supremacy in the last Jedi later
in a celebration montage to start
asteroid up the Ewoks sea appears to
have been split with a hold a maneuver
as resistance takes off along with the
Tantive poor or maybe just another CR 90
Corvette
lieutenant conics played by Billie lourd
Carrie Fisher's real-life daughter wears
a similar costume as Leia wore in the
final battle of Return of the Jedi with
the camo poncho in the single braid bun
on to the final battle of ex ago when
Rey enters the Sith temple she hears the
chanting of SIF mass which acoustically
echoes the sound design of the chanting
ghosts from The Shining ray finds
Palpatine who makes the same case to her
that he made to Luke and returned to the
Jedi goading her into striking him down
and tempting her by showing her fleet
losing the battle she seems to give in
and he says
[Music]
McDiarmid also drops a real solid heat
dewy
it's like he's seen the means and as
they did in the last Jedi ray and Ben
joined forces and Palpatine absorbed
some of their life force - like mummy
back his flesh and walk again when he
does his knives require the yellow
irises that he gained during this
transformation in Revenge of the Sith
Palpatine uses the surgeon power to
unleash sick lightning on the wrist is
distant fleet greeting and all is lost
moment for Po snap dies but Leto returns
in the Falcon wearing his classic yellow
shirt and pretty much every Star Wars
ship is in tow here there's the ghost
from rebels the hammerhead Corvette from
rogue one the razor crest from the
Mandalorian Mon Calamari cruisers Hans
freighter from the force awakens the
Bombers from the last Jedi
Dorian gun ships the Ewing from ro1
nebula B and C forgets and more than a
probably missing among the returning
pilots is wedge antilles with Denis
Lawson making a cameo zouri bliss also
returns to the fronts making good on her
earlier words to Poe but she told him
that they win by making you think you're
alone there's more of us and one by one
the US is take down each Star Destroyer
ray on her back repeats her be with me
prayer and looks up to the heavens
it's answered by the voices of Jedi past
feelin closely you can hear Luke along
with Yoda voiced by Frank Oz as always
Hayden Christensen as Anakin samuel l
jackson is mace windu liam neeson that's
quite gone genuine McGregor and Allegan
is voiced and obi-wan Freddie Prinze jr.
is kanan jarrus ashley eckstein as
ahsoka tano olivia Dabo as Luminara
Unduli Jennifer Hale as Aayla Secura
Angelique Perrin as a voice of Adi
Gallia's Jedi assemble and with her new
strength rate rises summons both Luke's
and Leia's blades and uses them to
deflect Palpatine Sith lightning to tear
apart his flesh like a Nazi who opened
the Ark of the Covenant
essentially what mace windu would have
done - Palpatine had Anakin not
interfere Ben rises and returns the
favor by saving Rey with his own force
Healing revived she calls him Ben and
touches his face reminding him of the
love that he felt from his parents and
they have a smooch and for the first
time ever in astrology Adam driver
smiles he and Leia fade as these Jedi
become one with the force in the ensuing
celebration John Williams Luke and Leia
theme plays over a montage of Bespin and
jakku in indoor with a cameo from
Warwick Davis as wicket the resistance
soldiers include a boffin the rebels
mentioned by Mon Mothma and returned the
Jedi and somewhere among them is a cameo
by Lin and well
Miranda Lando offers to help Janna find
a spin-off and thank God
Maz Kanata hands off Hans rebel
medallion to the wookie who got snubbed
in the first film I love how in the
closing shot of this party you can see
Chewie show it off to r2 in Threepio the
final scene returns us to Tatooine
ray passes Jawas in a sand crawler and
she finds the large moisture farm she
sleds down the dune as she did in the
force awakens and she buries luke's and
Leah's lightsabers near where Shmi was
buried ray shows off a new lightsaber
she built with a yellow blade which I
speculated in my indian explained video
that could connect her with the
guardians go check that out for more on
that but following the yellow red blue
pattern Ray's returning yellow here
could signal a reset a start of a new
adventure ray designed the hilt of her
lightsaber to resemble her bo staff and
it's symmetrical design makes me wonder
if the bottom is actually a secondary
blade now the hilt would probably need
to be longer for a practical dual wield
but it's just got small hands
chicken-egg work
an elderly woman rides by on a Tatooine
camel just like the one obi-wan rode up
to this farm and a final shot of Revenge
of the Sith but this woman asks who she
is and Ray says ray but this is a
stickler old camel woman so she asks ray
who bringing us back to that theme of
identity ray could say she's ray Papa
teen and scared the [ __ ] out of this
woman but rather than label herself as a
Star Wars equivalent of Hitler ray looks
out and sees Mirage like visions of Luke
and Leia's horse ghost smiling back at
her and Ray figures it out responds ray
Laila ray ghost siblings don't know ray
Skywalker rage whose's the identities
she fought for so that the Skywalker
legacy can live on a feeling of hope
that JJ Abrams underscores with the
final shot the binary sunset that
started this adventure forty-two years
ago and so concludes this analysis an
easter egg breakdown of the rise of
Skywalker but we still have more episode
9 videos in store for you so be sure to
subscribe to new rock stars and comment
down below with your favorite moment
from this film follow me on Instagram
and Twitter and ei vas thank you for
joining me
[Music]